I think the first time I've talked to
you was on clubhouse actually yeah I
mentioned something about robots and
like almost immediately went to
generating a bunch of ideas around oh
yeah uh it's just 100 Robots versus a
hundred humans yeah how far can a robot
throw a potato I think your idea like
the first idea was because you just said
so many ideas I never even thought of
but it's it's it shows the value of uh
basically brainstorming with people that
think differently but at the end of the
day my ideas were probably you know
might lean towards some people a little
bit younger than your audience like some
of the stuff yeah but there's still the
ideas like I think the first one you
said because we're talking about uh
quadruped like a robot dogs you said to
replace a biological dog with a robot
dog and see if the owner notices
something you're just quickly
brainstorming different ideas of like
how this was years ago I remember that
yeah which is just I mean it's like oh
yeah I never really thought about that
kind of sort of it's the basic the
tension between what does it take for a
robot and an AI system to replace the
biological systems that we the
biological creatures that we that we
love in our lives yeah and but like that
was like the um
the pace of idea generation
was the thing that struck me today and
in general it's like that's how you get
at good videos is you keep keep things
it's much easier to make a video around
a good idea obviously than a bad one
you're just setting yourself up for
success